your patience let's see I'm waiting for
my images to show up before I start to
talk hopefully my image will show up
before I start to talk there we are okay
good
what I'm here for is to give you a sort
of an introduction we're going to have a
discussion about open questions in
cosmology in a few minutes but I'm going
to give you an overview of our current
picture of the universe and I figured
since we're in New York I should begin
by telling you these are stars and you
may not have seen them before they're at
night they're up there and if but if you
go in the country you might see this
kind of picture this a globular cluster
and the stars are absolutely beautiful
but what we've learned in the last 25
years is that as beautiful as they are
they're really just the tip of a vast
cosmic iceberg and the really important
stuff is the stuff between the stars and
we are just beginning to learn about
that stuff and there are huge mysteries
that are related to it and I want to I
want to set the stage by explain to what
we know and most importantly what we
don't know about the universe so I
always begin with this guy who gives me
great faith in humanity now this is
Edwin Hubble he he began life as a
lawyer and then became an astronomer so
there's there's really his hope for
everybody and he changed our picture of
the universe
yeah tremendously and we're going to be
talking about history a little bit so I
just want to point out to put in
perspective his greatest discovery which
i'll talk about in a minute has to do
with with the way the dynamics of the
universe but about a little over 80
years ago when the first large telescope
Mount Wilson was built he he resolved a
big problem when people looked out in
our galaxy and by the way at that time
80 some odd years ago there was one
galaxy in the universe that was it our
Milky Way galaxy and when you looked in
with telescopes you saw some fuzzy
things that we called nebulae which is
Greek for fuzzy thing
and there was a big debate about what
they were and with that telescope he was
able to resolve the fact that in fact
these nebulae many of them were in fact
other Island universes other galaxies we
now know that there are 400 billion
galaxies in the observable universe and
80 years ago we knew of one so it's
we're we're like the early map makers in
fact one of the map makers is here and
we're going to talk on stage about this
stuff and we and it's therefore not
surprising that our picture of the
universe is dramatically changing all
the time it's a very exciting time in
cosmology but the discovery that he made
that that made him famous of course was
that the universe was not static and
eternal up to that point scientists that
was the conventional wisdom in science
that the universe had been around as it
was more or less forever and he
convinced the world that it wasn't by an
observation which he made these are not
sperm these are galaxies and and what he
what he discovered was that as we as he
looked out from our galaxy here at other
galaxies they're all on average moving
away from us and those that are twice as
far away from us are moving twice as
fast those are three times as far away
from us are moving three times as fast
etcetera everything is moving away from
us and this obviously tells you that we
are the center of the universe okay
now that's what it naively would suggest
when you look at it but it doesn't imply
that it implies the fact that the
universe is expanding uniformly and and
there are lots of different ways I've
tried to to demonstrate this to people
but I think the only way to really see
that this implies the universe is
expanding is is to get out of our myopic
position where we are in fact the really
the best way is to get outside of our
universe and look in and so what I've
done here is that is to draw a two
dimensional universe where we're outside
of it easily enough and we're looking at
a university now each I put each of the
galaxies a nice uniform distance apart
at some time t1 and now if the universe
is expanding all those galaxies are a
little bit further apart at some later
time so if you were standing outside the
universe it'd be obvious that the
universe was expanding but what would
you see if you're in that universe well
pick a galaxy any galaxy that one there
and to understand what it would look
like from that galaxy I'm just going to
superimpose this image on top of this
one placing this on top of where it was
before and what do you see you see
exactly what Hubble saw every galaxy is
moving away from that one and those that
are twice as far our way has moved twice
the distance at the same time those are
three times as far away three times etc
and the point is it doesn't matter where
you are
any place you are you see exactly the
same thing
everything is moving away from you so if
you're a pessimist there is no center of
the universe and optimist every place as
the center of the universe but what it
really means is that what Hubble saw
tells us that the universe is expanding
and that is profoundly important because
it changes cosmology and it's really one
of the reasons we're here because if the
universe is expanding yesterday was a
little smaller than it is today and the
day before a little smaller and if we
work backwards at one point a time that
we now know about 13.7 billion years ago
all of the observable galaxies in the
universe and all the matter associated
those with those galaxies was contained
in a region smaller than the size of a
baseball and that means to understand
that universe we don't just think about
astronomy but in fact about the physics
of the very small and if and what what
really this this is a famous alchemy
symbol for called the Ouroboros which is
a snake eating its own tail and that
really sort of represents cosmology
because the very biggest scales to
understand the universe of the very
biggest scales we really have to think
about physics at the very smallest
scales because of the earliest moments
of the Big Bang it was the physics of
the very smallest scales that determined
what would happen and those are the some
of the things were going to be talking
about in the panel later now this is
Hubble's data I'm not supposed to so
graphs here but I lied I'm doing it this
it's important to see this because it
gives you a sense of how cosmology has
changed and also one of the reasons why
he was such a great scientist in fact
because he knew to draw a straight line
through this data set but this is
velocity versus distance and he saw that
objects that are further away from us
are moving faster he interpreted this to
be now he did something very important
he got the answer wrong by about a
factor
ten and that's a tradition we've tried
to continue in astrophysics and but it
is the reason he did it was not that he
wasn't a good observer but it's very
difficult to determine how fast the
universe is expanding in fact it's taken
us 80 years to really get this down pat
because it well it's easy to measure
velocity it's hard to measure distance
velocity is easy to measure and in fact
these two Cowboys know how to do it
they're on the plane and one of them is
turn the other and says I love hearing
that lonesome wail of the train whistle
as the magnitude of the frequency the
wave changes due to the Doppler effect
and so we we see galaxies and moving
away from us and we know they're moving
away from us because we see the light
from those galaxies stretched out by the
Doppler effect and the long wavelength
end of the radiation is the red end of
the spectrum so when objects are moving
away from us we say they're red shifted
and what we found is that objects that
are farther away are red shifted more
than objects that are closer but the big
question is how do we know they're
farther away that's the hard part how do
you measure distance velocity is easy
distance isn't so easy in order to
measure distance you have to what we've
tried to find is something called a
standard candle an object whose
intrinsic brightness we believe we
understand like a hundred watt light
bulb I could measure the distance to the
back of the room if I turned off all the
lights except for 100 watt light bulb
but if I had an old-fashioned camera
older than many of the people in this
audience used to have a light meter if I
saw how much power was coming into my
camera and I knew it was onto a light
bulb back there I could work out how far
away the light bulb was so if the
universe were populated by hundred watt
light bulbs we'd be fine but it's not
and we have to look for the equivalent
something whose brightness we understand
we look through a telescope and see how
bright it appears if we know its
intrinsic brightness we can figure out
how far away it is and that's the hard
part of measuring distance and that's
been very hard for 80 years and in fact
what we now have is a great standard
candle and the first image I showed you
was this picture one of my favorite
pictures it's the galaxy far far away
and long long ago and and and this is a
bright star and now this star is as
bright as the center of this whole
galaxy and you would therefore think
that what it is is just a star in our
galaxy that got in the way the picture
but it isn't it's a star in the edge of
this galaxy and it is shining with the
brightness of ten billion stars what
happened well it's a star that's just
exploded it's a supernova and supernova
don't explode very often fortunately for
us they explode about once per hundred
years per galaxy but they do explode
which is important for all of you
because every atom in your body almost
was once inside an exploding star
because that's where all the heavy
elements on earth were made in exploding
star so you really are star children but
they don't explode very often and
therefore you might say how can we use
these things and and the other thing I
want to point out is that the amazing
thing about the universe is that it's
big and it's old and therefore rare
things happen all the time and if you
hold your hand out at arm's length and
held out about a dime-size hole and
looked at a dark spot in the sky if you
had a telescope that was powerful enough
you could see about a hundred thousand
galaxies and if you work it out once per
hundred year per galaxy a hundred
thousand galaxies on a given night you
would see ten stars explode you would
expect and astronomers do that they
actually make apply for telescope time
and say tonight I'm gonna see ten stars
explode and they might see nine they
makes eleven it might be cloudy or
whatever and we can use these objects in
fact these are new standard candles and
we can actually see them explode in real
time here's a little movie of a star
exploding in a distant galaxy can it it
they remain bright for about a month or
so we can measure the brightness and
from their colors we can tell what kind
of exploding star they are and a certain
type of supernova has become a wonderful
standard candle that has allowed us to
measure the expansion of the universe
and here's a new Hubble plot you can see
how much better we do this is of course
also after the important mathematical
discovery that on a log-log plot
everything is a straight line but in a
case we now can measure the Hubble
constant to about ten percent as opposed
to about a factor of ten and that may
not sound like much but it's really been
important and it's been important
because it turns out if we want to
determine the future of the universe we
have to understand the expansion rate
because as Einstein told us
with his general theory of relativity
which governs the dynamics of an
expanding universe we think and we'll
talk about to what extent it may or may
not ultimately discover those dynamics
but if it does then the neat thing about
general relativity is it tells us that
matter curved space energy radiation
matter can curve space and cause it to
dynamically respond by expanding
contracting etc and that means we live
in one of three types of universes
so-called open closed or flat universe
the geometry of those universes are
different and now of course these are
two-dimensional images it's a lot easier
to draw a two dimensional curved
universe than a three-dimensional one
which is why I have it here but what
really got us interested in why we
wanted to know and why in fact became a
cosmologists from originally doing
particle physics is it turns out that
well that what's really important about
these universes is in a closed universe
if it's full of matter alone it will
expand up to a certain point and then
contract into a reverse of the of the
Big Bang Big Crunch if you want so I
closed universe would expand and then
contract an open universe would expand
forever to find out rate and a flat
universe was just the boundary between
those two which would almost stop but
never quite stop and the real question
in cosmology over the 20th century was
what universe do we live in that's what
we wanted to know in order to know that
there's two things we have to know how
fast the universe is expanding measuring
the Hubble constant and how much matter
there is because we wanted to know
whether it was enough matter to curve
the universe and close it in a closed
universe literally if you look far
enough in that direction you'll see the
back of your head okay and so the idea
was to try and determine how much matter
there was measure the expansion rate and
determine if the universe were open
closed or flat and then we would know
whether our universe ended in a in a
bang or a whimper okay now we have been
able to do that and that those are the
things I want to talk about in the next
few minutes we've been weighing the
universe to determine how much matter
there is we now know how fast the
universe is expanding how much matter is
there how do you weigh the universe you
stand on the shoulders of giants this is
a an old guy named Tycho Brahe hey whose
work eventually allowed
Nutan to develop his theory of gravity
and eventually allowed us to delay the
earth and the Matt of the Sun and our
own galaxy but nowadays in fact we use
gravity to weigh the universe in a
slightly different way and I just want
to show you a picture which is worth a
thousand words in this case this is the
way we can actually and this is only
been possible in the last decade or so
determine how much matter there is in
the universe by weighing the largest
objects in the universe this is what
most galaxies hang out in clusters this
is a picture one of many Hubble like
pictures which are really amazing every
point in that picture is not a star but
a galaxy and every galaxy contains
roughly a hundred billion stars so every
one of these has billions of stars in it
maybe with civilizations around them
long ago gone because these images are
these objects are billions of
light-years away many of the stars no
longer exist and the but the interesting
thing about this cluster of galaxies
these are this clusters are the largest
bound objects in the universe if we can
weigh them we can weigh anything
and this picture allows us to weigh this
cluster because you know you don't do a
rocket scientist to see there's
something weird about this picture there
all these blue things and this is an
image of something in Einstein first
predicted in 1937 but said we'd never
observe because he underestimated
observers which is easy to do it's a
phenomena called gravitational lensing
Einstein told us that mass curved space
and if I have a big enough mass and I
have an object behind that big enough
mass emitting light the light will Bend
around it and that light can be
magnified just as the light going
through my glasses is magnified so I can
see all of you or if I had a very
irregular surface like a crystal goblet
if I looked in it I'd see many different
images of all of you and that's exactly
what's happening here we now know that
each of these images these blue things
are different images of a single galaxy
located billions of light years behind
this cluster and the light from that
galaxy has been magnified and distorted
so we see many different copies of the
galaxy due to gravity now it's a
beautiful phenomena but it allows us to
weigh the cluster B
we know how general relativity works and
we can ask how much mass is in this
system and where is it distributed so we
can see this this image and here is the
the inversion of this image to determine
where the mass is in this system where
each of this little bumps is is where a
galaxy is but what you see first of all
very importantly is that most of the
mass by far the majority of the mass in
this system is not with the galaxy's
honor it's between the galaxies it's
stuff that doesn't shine and we now know
that almost 30 times as much stuff in
the universe is out there and is dark
it's compared to all the stars and all
the galaxies and everything we can see
30 times as much stuff and physicists
with their great linguistic perspicacity
if called the stuff dark matter okay and
one of the big mysteries is what is this
dark matter and one of the things that
makes it really exciting is that we
realize there's too much dark matter to
be made up of normal stuff for argue I
don't have time to explain the arguments
but we know pretty for very good reasons
to believe that that dark matter is not
made of protons and neutrons and the
same stuff that you and I are made of
it's we think it's made of some new type
of elementary particle created in the
earliest moments of the Big Bang a part
elementary particle doesn't interact
with matter like you like normal matter
does and what makes that interesting is
that we don't just need telescopes there
to for to find it if it's uniformly
distributed in galaxies like our own
galaxy it's in this room it's going
right through your bodies as you doze
off during this lecture okay and that
means we can build detectors to look for
it in fact there are detectors
underground around the world like this
one which has a block of germanium cool
to very close to absolute zero and most
of dark matter particles are going right
through this thing without ever knowing
it's there but every now and then one
may bounce off it we hope depositing a
little bit of energy heating the whole
thing up so we can measure it and then
we could try and determine maybe what
this stuff is made of but what but to go
back to that other picture what we've
been able to know in fact
physicists whenever they have an
important number give it a Greek letter
and so we call this thing Omega and what
we've been able to measure is Omega is
0.3 what does that mean
Omega tells us how much matter there is
in the universe compared to how much
matter we need to have to make the
universe just closed on itself if I make
is 1 the universe is flat make us bigger
than 1 the universe is closed and if
it's less than 1 it's open so we seem to
have discovered with great accuracy that
we live in an open universe that big
holy grail of cosmology looks like it's
been finally solved we live in an open
universe but there's a problem first of
all a theoretical problem theorists knew
that the universe couldn't be open Omega
has to be one
we knew that why because Omega 1 is the
only pretty number and so we figured it
had to be 1 and there's a big problem
because none of the observations told us
it was 1 and so there's a big problem as
as we finally got this number down pat
it caused a big puzzle but now there's
another way it turns out we can measure
the geometry of the universe instead of
adding up matter and comparing it to the
expansion in the universe we can
actually measure the geometry of the
universe directly and we can do it using
one of the strongest tools in cosmology
that we'll talk about in fact Lyman
pages here is one of the people
directing one of the programs to look
for this stuff so the question is how
would you measure the geometry of the
universe well the question you can ask
is how would you measure that the earth
is curved if you couldn't go around it
you couldn't sit in a satellite and see
it well very simple you draw a triangle
and then you ask a European high school
student what's the sum of the angles in
the Triangle and then they tell you 180
degrees ok and you say ok you learned
your geometry from Euclid but in fact on
a curved surface like the surface of the
earth I can draw a triangle that's very
different if I take a triangle why I go
along the equator make a right angle go
to the North Pole make another right
angle come back to the equator I now
have a triangle with three right angles
and three right angles adds up to 270
degrees so if I could draw big enough
triangle on the surface of the earth and
see that it differed from 180
Riis I know that the earth is curved it
turns out that that thinking works
exactly the same for a curved
three-dimensional universe if we could
draw a big enough triangle and measure
the angles we know whether we lived in
open closed or flat universe and that's
what we've been able to do in the last
10 years or so we've done it using this
great observable in cosmology that's
really turned cosmology into a precision
empirical science it's called the cosmic
microwave background radiation the
afterglow of the Big Bang it was
discovered by accident in New Jersey of
all places about 40 years ago
by two people who really didn't know
what they were doing but we won't go
into that it's the afterglow of the Big
Bang and what is it well when we look
out at galaxies that are say a billion
light years away we we're doing cosmic
archaeology because we're looking at
them as they looked a billion years ago
now given that you'd think if the
universe is 14 billion years old or so
if you looked out 14 billion light years
shouldn't I see the Big Bang the answer
is yes if you could but you can't and
the reason you can't is well the same
reason I can't look outside this room
the wall is opaque I can't see past the
wall and if I look out the universe
earlier in earlier times the universe
was hotter and hotter and hotter and at
a certain time the universe was so hot
when it was a hundred thousand years old
it was so hot that the universe was
three thousand degrees and at that
temperature was hot enough so that
hydrogen which is the dominant stuff in
the universe gets broken apart into
protons and electrons charged particles
and it becomes what's called a plasma
and a plasma is opaque to radiation so
we can't see past this point because the
universe is opaque here now let's run
the film forward the universe is cooling
down and it gets to a point when it
cools down to 3,000 degrees Kelvin
protons capture electrons become neutral
the universe becomes transparent and
just like this room I can see all the
way back to the point where the universe
was opaque and what I would expect if
there was a big bang was to see
radiation coming at me from all
directions at the point when the
universe first became transparent and
that radiation was 3,000 degrees in
temperature then but it's been cooling
down and
we would expect it to be about three
degrees and that's the cosmic microwave
background radiation that's been
discovered and what makes it so neat is
if we look at that radiation we get a
picture of what the universe looked like
when it was only a hundred thousand
years old now pictures so profoundly
interesting it's already two Nobel
Prizes have been given for it but for
our purposes there's one distant scale
that matters on that picture and that's
one degree across why one degree well
that's about a hundred thousand light
years across now Einstein tells us that
no signal can move faster than speed of
light and that means if this is a
hundred thousand light years at the time
it's getting so scared that it's shaking
that the time the universe was a hundred
thousand years old guys back there
stopped drinking okay then then no
information could travel from here to
here that's if I send out a light beam
it can only travel that far at that
surface that means nothing that happens
here can affect anything that happens
over there and that's interesting
because let's say I have a lump of
matter that's that big well it knows
it's a lump it should it should still
start to collapse and then I'll heat up
and pressure will respond then all sorts
of interesting things will happen but if
I have a lump that's this big it doesn't
know to collapse
it's like wily coyote when it goes over
the cliff okay doesn't know what
coaching because light can't travel
across it and gravity can't even travel
across it so it doesn't know what should
collapse are the largest objects that
will have significant you begun to
collapse at that point are one degree
across or so that's the ruler because if
we look out at this known distance we
have a ruler it's a hundred thousand
light-years across and we look at it we
say what's well if the universe is flat
light rays travel in straight lines and
that means the angle I would expect to
see on a roll or a hundred thousand
light years across at that point would
be one degree but if the universe is
open then light rays diverge as we go
back in time and I expect to see the
ruler would look smaller
it would only subtend say half a degree
on my eye if the universe is closed the
ruler will look bigger because light
rays converge so all I have to do is
look at that image and say what size are
these lumps are they half a degree one
degree two degrees across and
that's the type of thing that we've been
just begun to be able to do in the last
decade one of the first experiments to
be able to do it was on on the earth in
fact in Antarctica it was this is a
microwave radiometer this is a balloon
and this thing was taken away above the
earth because it's looking for a
background it's three degrees the earth
is much hotter than that so you want to
get above the atmosphere and this
balloon went around the world which is
easy to do in Antarctica and it in fact
right here it's really easy to do but
here it took about two weeks to go
around came back to where it began which
is why this experiment is called the
boomerang experiment and it took an
image of the microwave background
radiation and here's one version of this
image where the original picture is put
on top that this is just to demonstrate
our cosmic myopia because you know
during we've evolved and I'm allowed to
say that because I'm not in Ohio we've
evolved so that our eyes detect visible
radiation and if however we evolved to
detect microwave radiation day or night
we look out and we'd see that microwave
background radiation and these hot spots
and cold spots and that radiation are
the lumps and the question is how big
are they well this is these this is the
a different false color image of this
these are images of a universe created
on a computer if we live in a closed
universe the lumps average lump should
be this big we live in an open
University average lump should be about
that big well this is bigger than these
lumps this is smaller than these lumps
but just like Goldilocks if we live in a
flat universe it's just right and I
think I have I hope yes the much better
image taken with the W Maps satellite
which Lima page we'll talk about which
shows us we can do the same thing over
the whole sky and and it turns out we
can do a much better much more accurate
analysis and we find out two great
precision that the universe is flat now
there's a problem if you've been awake
we prove the universe was open there was
enough matter to make the universe flat
we've now proved the universe is flat
where's all that extra energy we only
have 30% of the amount of stuff and to
make a flat universe but we live in a
flat universe where could that extra
stuff be well
it could be right in empty space this is
a picture of what empty space really
looks like it's not so empty due to laws
of quantum mechanics and relativity
empty space is a boiling bubbling brew
of virtual particles that pop in and out
of existence in a time so short you
can't even measure them in general and
you might say well that's like counting
angels on the head of a pin or something
you can't see their effects directly but
their indirect effects are profoundly
important in fact this is a picture of
what space inside of a proton looks like
these particles are popping in and out
of existence and they're actually
responsible for most of the mass of a
proton most of the mass of your body is
not due to the quarks that are sitting
in the protons but due to these fields
that power popping in and out of
existence so they're vitally important
now if empty space has stuff in it like
this popping in and out of existence and
it can give mass to the proton maybe
empty space can have energy and we can
ask the same kind of physics that tells
us this how much energy does a gift
empty space we do the calculation we
come up with the worst prediction in all
of physics we predict about a gazillion
times as much energy in empty space as
there is in all matter in the universe
and that is pretty worrisome now a long
time when I was a graduate student this
problem has been around for a long time
we solved it very simply in our minds we
said a miracle occurs and somehow we get
rid of all that and the energy of empty
space is zero that seemed about the only
sense of a way of solving the problem
but physics isn't empirical science and
what if empty space has energy well
general relativity tells us that if you
put energy and empty space it's not
gravitationally attractive like
everything else it's gravitationally
repulsive it produces a repulsion and
what would that do if I put energy and
empty space here in the universe what
would it do well the University of was
expanding instead of slowing down with
speed up and about eight years ago
people used those supernovae to try and
measure the velocity of supernovae as a
function of distance away from us and in
a sensible universe that we should
measure something to look like that as
universe slows down if
was accelerating if it was dominated by
the energy of empty space it should look
like this 1998 a remark of two different
groups found a remarkable result this
may not look that remarkable but in fact
here's this Hubble curve I showed you
earlier and if I just for fun draw a
straight line through this and try and
make it horizontal here if the universe
was slowing down these distant
supernovae would fall along this curve
and they don't they're above the
straight line and what does that tell us
it tells us that the expansion of the
universe is speeding up and just for fun
if we try and fit that curve what do we
get we get 70% of the amount of energy
needed to make the universe flat must
exist in empty space that's exactly what
we were missing
so everything holds together with this
cockamamie universe that we don't
understand at all the universe is
dominated by the energy empty space we
don't understand why it's there we don't
have the slightest understanding why
it's there and if anyone comes out and
tells you they do especially if they're
a string theorist you shouldn't believe
them sorry Brian wherever you are but uh
but we think one of the things that
makes the most something what's so
exciting about we don't understand it
but we think it's related to the physics
of maybe the beginning of time which is
what we're going to talk about in the
panel among other things and so
measuring it and trying to understand it
may give us important information about
how the universe began and it will
ultimately determine our future and I
want to have a New York poet here so I
quote Yogi Berra who said the future
ain't what it used to be and it turns
out our picture of the universe's future
the universe is vastly different and
maybe we'll talk about it maybe we won't
but I just want to point out that that's
where we're at we live in this
cockamamie universe we if you take away
everything we see the universe would be
largely the same
we are completely insignificant
everything we see all the stars and
galaxies planets aliens everything take
away them we are just a 1% bit of
pollution in a universe that's dominated
by dark matter and dark energy and we
don't know the make up of dark matter
and we don't have the slightest
understanding of the
energy so it's incredibly exciting if
you're a theorist and incredibly
challenging if you're an experimentalist
and I don't know what the future is
going to bring but I do know that every
time we open up a new window on the
universe it surprises us and we have a
lot of new windows that are going to
open up and the large scale we have next
generation Space Telescope and other
proposed experiments that are gonna try
and probe dark energy on the smallest
scales in fact this year a new huge
particle accelerator is turning on in
fact it's very month in Geneva
Switzerland because we don't have enough
money in this country to spend for these
things and it is going to turn on and
Pruce the highest energy collisions that
have ever been observed on earth through
trying to recreate the earliest moments
of the Big Bang with incredible
detectors built underground the Gothic
cathedrals of the 21st century and the
information about the beginning of the
universe may come from the websites
telescope it may come from the Large
Hadron Collider with that Earl Burroughs
understand the universe and the largest
and smallest scales so to end this
little introduction I want to just say
two things okay first you are completely
insignificant and secondly it turns out
the future is miserable but you should
not be depressed because with the new
with with our telescopes and our
accelerators we have been as you can see
in the last years changing our picture
of the universe more than we could have
imagined beforehand and so instead of
worrying about the future and our and
our insignificance in it we should
really revel in the fact that we living
in the middle of nowhere in a remote
corner of the universe have an
intelligence and endowed intelligence
that we can use to understand the
universe and so instead of being
depressed we should enjoy our brief
moment in the Sun thank
and to see
you know yesterday Lawrence didn't know
a thing but he did say to comfort in
last night I think it and sort of
learned all that over night I want to
invite our panelists come on up invite
our panelists to come and take the
chairs we have for the next 45 minutes
we're going to pick up where Lawrence
left off and talk about those first few
instances at the beginning what happened
at the beginning how do we know what
happened at the beginning what is the
beginning all about was there something
before the beginning you know well and
we have a distinguished panel of experts
we were going to talk to us about it let
me introduce them sitting right next to
me is a Lyman page he studied the
earliest universe by measuring the
imprint left on the cosmos by the Big
Bang the Lawrence talked about the
microwave background radiation Lyman
Paige studies that he is a physicist the
Henri de Wolfe Smith professor physics
of Princeton University welcome to the
panel great to be here
now what is the significance of all of
this and where does it fit in history
and then cultures trying to discuss
where we came from and where we're
heading and that's why we invited Helle
crog he is one of the world's leading
historians of cosmology he's the author
of several books about the history of
physics and he comes all away from
Denmark from the department health
history of science department at the
University of Aris in Denmark welcome
and elegant craic
now now Lawrence talked about the Big
Bang Theory and how everything started
for the Big Bang but that may not be the
only ideas about the idea about how the
universe started so Paul Steinhardt is
here to talk about those first first few
microseconds and other possibly other
competing theories he is a theoretical
physicist he is one of the architects of
this inflationary model which says that
the universe began as this rapid
accelerated expansion surely after the
Big Bang and he is the Albert Einstein
professor of science and professor of
theoretical physics at Princeton
University welcome to the panel Paul ok
and of course Lawrence will be here to
kibbutz whenever he can about what we're
talking about hopefully he'll he'll
stick around I'm sure he will have some
great information to add but I want to
ask you a Paul Steiner
about universes about the one of the
problems the big problem that they were
outlining at the end of their talk was
how does something come out of nothing
how do we have a universe that comes out
of nothing or did it not come out of
nothing well that's a fundamental
question which challenges everything we
know about physics because we know of no
phenomenon in nature where say the
things come in and then nothing comes
out or you begin with nothing and then
something something occurs so we don't
we know of no phenomenon in nature which
has this this this property that we
observe in our everyday world so it's a
it's a theorists are really speculating
that somehow something is special about
the Big Bang that's different than any
other phenomenon that we've seen when
they had this idea of a beginning for
this very reason that's there are some
of us that think that maybe that's the
wrong idea the Big Bang is not the
beginning but there's something that
comes before and there's actually trace
things back such as well one of the idea
is that would that's that some of us
have been thinking about is that in fact
there was a whole universe evolving
before the bang a universe that went
through the same sort of history as
we've observed since the bang it
continued this way of ollying for a
period say a trillion year
then the sequence events occurred where
after it sort of emptied out of all the
matter and radiation that it is it had
expanded enough that the matter of
radiation was almost perfectly dilute
due to the acceleration that that effect
that Lawrence mentioned suddenly
gravitational energy is transformed into
new matter and radiation which begins a
new period of evolution this could
repeat itself in a cyclical way so maybe
the Big Bang is not the beginning maybe
maybe it's a transformational event and
that it and that the the evolution of
the universe is cyclical so those up
over and over and over again that's
right so they of course people are going
to say what happened before that okay
before the sick cycling began well is
this you can't get away with that answer
it so we're toying with this crowd I can
see it that's right well I mean there's
two logical possibilities there was some
beginning but it wasn't the Big Bang it
was some event that occurred many cycles
ago or one of the interesting ideas is
that it could have been cycles forever
like or that are constantly number
cycles is our concept is time is wrong
that's right that's that's that's right
so that we have to we have to change our
views of things and and and these and
this leads to two different pictures of
where everything in the universe came
from where all the structure we see in
the universe came from that we can
actually distinguish experimentally how
long is busted here let me get it fix
them yes I want to emphasize that we
need to be very cautious with the terms
that we use and that there is a whole
lot of difference about speaking of the
origin of the universe that the universe
has existed for a limited span of time
and then to speak about a universe which
came into being or even worse a created
universe because these words are not the
same I sometimes I like to phrase this
philosophical insight which is quite
trivial really by saying that we know
that the universe has an
each of approximately 13 billion years
and yet it has always existed this is a
true statement
there's a no contradiction between these
two parts of the sentence tell me why
because the term always refers
necessarily to time it's a temporal
concept and to say that the universe has
always existed merely tell says that we
cannot have a concept of time without a
universe so time began at the beginning
of the universe yes I mean whatever
model or view we have of the universe
because the universe is everything
physical including time and space then
the the claim that the universe has
always assisted is true a priori alarm
for the moment the defender of the Big
Bang
and say two things it responsible said
first of all as as unusual is to imagine
a universe beating from nothing in fact
it's not so crazy because one of the
reasons of flat universe is so pretty
for theorists is if you add up the total
energy of a flat universe it dad's up to
zero and that's one of the read many
reasons why all of us Paul even a decade
ago probably would have argued that the
universe was flat because if you're
going to imagine a universe began that
began with nothing a good value for the
total energy is zero now how can the
energy add up to zero well it turns out
gravitational energy can be both
positive and negative and a flat
universe is one in which the energy
balances the positive energy of motion
is balanced by the negative
gravitational attraction and the two add
up to zero and so it is possible to
imagine a universe that began from
nothing
it's and and then with regard to the
time question that's not only a
philosophical question is actually a
physics question and it could all it
could be from a physics sense that time
literally began at the Big Bang because
general relativity at least tells us
that space and time are related to the
matter and it as they get very very
dense we know the laws of physics as we
now understand them break down
and it could be the time itself wasn't a
relevant quantity at the beginning so
the answer to what happened before the
Big Bang is it's not a good question
not for you for me as a panel moderator
I think it's a great what
yes Bhopal so just to clarify when I was
talking about the cyclical idea I wasn't
arguing that it's logically impossible
that the Big Bang was the beginning it
just baby physically incorrect there may
actually it may actually be that the
structure of the universe as we see
today was not created by events that
occurred after the bang but it was
actually created by events that occurred
before the bank and we can actually see
the evidence of that through the kinds
of measurements that Lyman and his
colleagues are attempting to make and
then we wouldn't be able to answer the
question whether it was one story or the
other story whether the Big Bang was the
beginning of time or not well I mean let
me ask you good you want to pick up on
that or yeah I want to bring your props
in right go get to them in a second yeah
so the amazing thing that's happened in
cosmology in the last say 20 years is
that you can have these discussions that
were that you've heard about in these
notions from Lawrence and they're based
in measurement that's the whole new
thing and they're based and and so
Lawrence showed you a couple of pictures
and what I like to do is just take a
step back give you a sense for them and
give you some idea of how it can be so
confident of of what we're what we're
talking about and that we can and how
these questions are posed so if you can
put up this first picture of the Hubble
Deep Field the Hubble ah wonderful ok so
let me let me stand over here so I can
point so Lawrence showed a piece of this
and what I wanted to what I just wanted
to to give you a sense for is what what
we study in cosmology in the sizes you
heard a few numbers right you know the
moon right you can drive a good car to
the moon it's only 250,000 miles away or
about a light second right in the Sun is
about eight light minutes okay so in
each one of these guys here that you can
see are a hundred billion suns ok so so
that's a large number
right so one way to remember it is Bill
Gates has a dollar for every star in our
galaxy in the Milky Way okay so here so
and now this is this is a huge this is a
big picture right and that's and that's
all light that picture is one fiftieth
the size of the full moon okay so take
50 of those to make the full moon now if
you then go and count up all the
galaxies if you did this over all the
sky was the other number that that
Lawrence told you is about 400 billion
so maybe you know that was the height of
the Internet era so it's the same number
right of galaxies in the observable
universe okay so that's the first thing
and remember those are those are those
are just pictures you know these are
little agglomerations of mass each one
in galaxies each one 100 billion suns
okay so now let me wonder if you can put
up the egg and I want to good so this is
the pitch the last picture the Hubble
was relatively recently you look back
you know billion billions of years this
is if you look back 13.7 billion years
right and you could see the first
picture was in light that you see like
this you know just like the lights in
this room just like what you see looking
through binoculars this picture since
it's the universe you trace it back
through what Lawrence told you since it
was so much younger and so much more
compact it's an older these lightweight
let's forget the compact form it we'll
get back to that these since it's so
much older the light from here is not an
optical wavelengths but it's at
millimetre wavelengths so here's a way
to think about this and this is the
stuff so this is an image of the sky I'm
going to show you what would we know
today that's at millimeter wavelengths
what is it
Razors a TV a typical TV station is at
centimeter wavelengths a few centimeters
like some of the TV stations broadcast
elements of it at centimeter wavelengths
so here's the picture I want you to get
from that what is that that's if we take
the whole sky
and we're at and we plaster it flat on a
screen so this is what you should be
thinking of so this is a beach ball of
the whole universe that light is
Lawrence told you it's from the edge of
the universe okay so it's like so this
is the picture those 1-degree spots she
was talking about are all the blue and
red spots on here these are tiny
variations in the intensity of power
from when this radiation was emitted so
just a few hundred thousand years after
the Big Bang
so this is so the picture then to have
is that this is looking back to the edge
of the observable universe all those
galaxies are happening or took place and
or you see them inside the speech ball
what's on the outside of the Beedrill
okay so great so so the outside of the
beach ball is more beach ball okay so
the universe let me past you so I have a
couple of these that can pass these
around we're gonna take a way of just
really yeah let's look at so the
universe oh the picture here and these
and these guys cannot pass this back
okay the universe now is in our we're
thinking about is infinite okay and it
always has been infinite we owe and went
so that's what I want to get back to the
compact right the part we see that beach
ball inside that beach ball was more
compact you know down to the grapefruit
size early on but there's but what
happens is this radiation such as the
speed of light it travels the age of the
universal reaches us carves out a piece
of the universe that's accessible and
that's what we call the observable
universe so when we think of space it's
it we think of it as being infinite and
we just access access a small chunk of
it thank you
okay great is that yeah thank you good
Helen let me ask you this is a question
that's been asked by the Greek
philosophers basically we're talking
about the same question where did we all
come from right where we headed because
that's what this is this ball is going
to talk about
yes that's relating a course to man's
place than universe or the role of
humanity compared to the universe as
such and that was part a very important
part in early cosmology but as we heard
in very that directly expressed we are
totally insignificant and I'd like to
enter at just two small saying that this
sort of insight or recognition that not
only humanity but also the earth is an
insignificant place and universe is
sometimes known as Copernican principles
because in a certain sense it goes back
to the same sixteenth century and for a
very long time it has been a paradigm in
scientific cosmology that the earth has
snow is no privileged place that the
time that that we live in is not
privileged and that human observers are
not privileged but as you may know some
of you may know for a couple of decades
a new controversial point of view or
principle named the entropic principle
has created a lot of discussion in
cosmology and physics and elsewhere and
this principle although it exists in
many different versions tell us
essentially that that human observers
are not insignificant they are all
important the name and tropic is after
all derived from the Greek name of
humans and well there are different
points of view with regard to the
entropic principle but some people
including Marty Rees take it very
seriously other people will say that
it's not true signs it has no
explanatory power and it's a worrying
return to philosophical and even see
logic exploited again a little
what years are you saying that the fact
that anything is here the anthropic
pissed we the reason anything is here is
because we are here to observe it a call
they make it happen yes indeed according
to the so-called a strong version of the
entropic principle the existence well
not necessarily of humans but the
existence of beings being made up of
carbon atoms in some advanced
combinations can't be said to be the
reason for the existence of the entire
universe all right at that of course
simpler if you think of the possibility
of many universes which many of how I
get it to that yeah and it's currently
in physics we think it's quite likely
there many universes then you can
imagine and so it's it's a little less
mysterious if you put it that way
because they say well in each universe
say the laws of physics could be a
little bit different or the initial
conditions could be a little bit
different and it turns out of course
unless things were just right so you
could have galaxies if you didn't have
galaxies you couldn't have stars but if
you didn't have stars you would have
planets if you'd have planets you would
have astronomers and so it so the fact
that we're here just validates that the
laws of physics have to be able to
produce astronomers it's like an
intelligent fish asking why is the
universe made of water if it wasn't the
fish wouldn't be there to ask the
question so it's it's a little less
mysterious if you put it that way and
then and so the question is is there any
fundamental reason why the laws of
physics are as they are or could there
be anything and they just are as they
are because if they were any different
we wouldn't be here to measure it and
that's the current debate that's
happening in physics largely because of
this energy of empty space which is so
weird
that has caused some physicists to go
crazy right but actually I move down an
aisle phone actually it's more than that
that made it really ties together this
whole story that beach ball that Lyman
is showing in having has in his lap
there that pattern has two possible
explanations one that arises if the is
that if the universe has a beginning if
that's if that happened through
point seven billion years ago was the
beginning then the only way we know how
to make that pattern and make the
flatness and the smoothness of the
universe BC is to have a period of
inflation and the original idea is that
what inflation did it took an initially
chaotic universe and made it everywhere
the same inflation for people don't
understand inflation there's some rapid
it's a period like the present day
acceleration but at a much more rapid
rate that I would have heard
shortly after this beginning and would
have taken some random distribution of
energy smoothed it out and then this
inflationary energy would have decayed
into the matter we see and that's how we
got to be the way we are and it would
have left because this is decay of
energy occurs through a random quantum
process it wouldn't have occurred
everywhere exactly at the same time it
would have left some regions hotter or
cooler than the others producing a
pattern which agrees beautifully with
the measurements in that beach ball that
is so that is one possible explanation
but along with that I but there's a
surprise like sort of kicker with that
idea which is that it doesn't do quite
what we thought it doesn't make
everywhere the universe the same once
inflation starts it never really stops
there are always due to rare quantum
fluctuations some pieces of the universe
that continue to inflate so in fact what
really happens with inflation is that it
inflates AB large piece of the universe
part of it decays into matter and
radiation leaving a pocket of stuff ok
well the rest of it B continues to
inflate then another decay process
occurs another pocket universe occurs
which contains stuff another one another
one so you get this multiverse picture
and one of the problems or issues is
these different pockets have different
physical properties so for example we
point to this map and we say the
universe is flat ah inflation flattens
the universe but actually there's an
infinite number of these pockets in
which the universe is not flat an infant
number which are so we end up with this
idea there's different possibilities for
the universe for its flatness or not
flatness or for its physical laws so the
reflection leaves have your cake and eat
it then you can well it's not well I I
view it a problem I view it is I mean I
call this the unpredictability problem
because it means that you thought you
had a theory that explained the universe
but actually it produced many different
universes other than the one
that you see in addition to the one that
you see instead of simplifying it
actually made it more come well admit in
fact the deposited now it may change the
nature science because you got asked it
you know instead of a theory of
everything it's a theory of anything
right and and theory of anything is it
science I mean if you could explain
anything you can see then you could
never falsify it and that's a big worry
it's a big worry in modern physics
something that I just want to follow up
on on how then Lawrence's comments I
mean the the thing the reason you can
talk about these wild things and and
anyone will listen are their scientists
is you can make measurements right and
that's and the thing is multiverses no
one knows how to make a measurement that
can say whether that is true or not the
only way to get at that is to follow
through and make some prediction which
has an effect on the universe that we
see the anthropic principle same thing
there are no predictions and so for
making headway and this is this is a
philosophical you can see were very
different for making headway you have to
make models that make predictions and
again the key thing with this like with
it with this measurement is since we can
measure the sky so well now measure this
this cosmic microwave background
radiation we can measure it so well
we're on the verge of of making
measurements of detailed predictions of
say the inflationary model of the
universe it says the sky has to act just
like this and and we in fact are seen
that another way this is taking
Lawrence's picture when we look at these
hot and cold spots these are pictures of
the quantum mechanics of the early
universe written a large across the sky
and by looking at them in detail we can
start to sort out these these various
theories and it's it's it's stunning
that's what keeps us all up at night
doing this it's really exciting and it's
it's it's happening so is there any way
to actually settle which picture is
corrected you said now we can test out
some of these things I would like to say
that yeah right that the alternative
iris mentioned the cyclical idea does
not lead to this multi universe picture
so really what's at stake is not just a
question of is it inflation or a cyclic
model or a quest
to know whether there was something
before the Big Bang but are we going to
be forced to this idea of multiverse and
we can't we can only understand a small
section of the universe and anything was
possible
this kind of science or pseudoscience or
are we going to be led to an idea of a
unified universe and so that's also at
stake what why do we believe is that you
brought up the multiverse why should we
think there is such a thing well Paul
already mentioned that that the best
ideas we have or at least one of the
best ideas we have the early universe
naturally predicts many other universal
it predicts that phenomena in fact it's
kind of philosophically almost like
returning in the steady state universe
and the largest scales if this picture
is true on the largest scales at any
instant there's always some universe
being born and another one maybe but
wouldn't we feel the effects of another
universe no we wouldn't and could we be
in the middle of one or no and so the
question is is this philosophy and I
want to get back to Lyman's point it
isn't it's actually physics because for
the following reason let's say we
actually had a theory which we don't
have but let's say we had a theory that
actually predicted the mass of the
proton the mass of the electron why
there are three generations of
elementary particles while there are
four forces in nature all of these
things but it also predicted that there
had to be this phase of inflation in the
early universe well we would make a
hundred predictions that we could
measure and test and one that we
couldn't that there are other universes
and so we pretty well believe that those
other universes are out there it could
also but the key point is that it's good
that these models also and one of the
things that sort of the theory that
Paul's promoting versus inflation it
does some of these things do predict
measurable differences in those in that
pattern of dots and so we're not
guaranteed by any means that we're going
to be able to settle this but there's
great excitement about the possibility
that by measuring that pattern of dots
or even looking for something even more
interesting called gravitational waves
from the early universe we may be able
to distinguish these pictures we don't
know what the future is going to bring
which is why it's interesting stay tuned
yeah but we need to keep looking
question here yes sir hi just first a
quick clarification question for Lyman
in terms of could use as the beach poles
are running around the audience here we
explain the apparent discrepancy between
the beach ball and the picture in terms
of the
for example the large stripe without
registration things like that so that's
my first question sharp audience yeah
okay sure so so yikes
Oh universe on the loose here we go
hatred peril yeah yes that one so we're
in the galaxy right and we have to look
out to the galaxy that picture that we
splash around has the galaxy subtracted
this one because we're right in the
middle right looking out we have to look
out to the galaxy so this this red ring
around here is looking out through the
gallery our to our galaxy the Milky Way
okay right second for the panel um in
terms of the kind of many universes
theory that's recently kind of cropped
up could you relate that or not relate
that to when people first realized that
superposition existed and one sense was
let's different states collapse Super's
in collapses to one state or the other
obviously Everett another said no maybe
they don't collapse maybe two universes
you know so when we observe something
and it looks like this beam was split
and it went to this way and that way and
then it it it collapsed one way or the
other no Everett said no two universes
were created upon that observation that
the observation itself created now two
strands two streams can you relate the
two or do you find them completely
different and finally all right ways
anybody know what he's talking about
okay maybe a few people Laurence
Illustrated oh yeah okay so that
unfortunately there's many different
ways of talking about many universes and
physics and and then this is actually
different the quantum mechanics is
really fascinating because it says that
on small scales the universe is really
crazy and objects can do many different
things at the same time too bad you
don't like it too bad that's the way it
is and it turns out when you actually
measure it you find out well no was
doing one thing what what the picture
he's talking about it suggests is when
you measure it yeah you force it to be
doing one thing but in fact every
measurement because the object was doing
many things every measurement forces you
to exist on what what's called one
branch of many universes and in a
different you know had you had the
quantum mechanical measurement come out
a different way you would come out with
a different number and in a different in
a different universe
be asking the questions and I would be
answering them and and and it's just
there are many many universes and we're
always measuring on every time we look
out we create a new universe it's a it's
a weird and crazy picture to try and
understand quantum mechanics but it's
very different than this picture this
picture has many physical universes in
the same if you wish the same quantum
mechanical branch of the wavefunction
oh my Cara thank you yeah well as is the
idea of inflation necessarily that
matter has moved at speeds perhaps grade
in the speed of light or that the way we
measure has changed that the ruler has
changed well so when we talk about
inflation it fits in this idea of
expansion like the Hubble expansion that
Lawrence described except that the rate
of expansion is increasing with time so
for example imagine a situation where
the universe doubles in size every 10
billion years that's roughly speaking
what seems to be happening in the
universe right now so space stretches by
a factor of two in every direction every
10 billion years so something which a
distant galaxy which is now say a
million light years from now will and 10
billion light years be twice that and
another 10 billion light years twice
that again so it's gone twice as far in
the next 10 billion years as in the
first and then another 10 billion years
it goes yet twice as far as that so it's
it's separation from us that's picking
up with time if you could imagine that
situation if it continues over time it
ventually dilutes or spreads out all the
matter in the universe to the point
where the universe becomes essentially
empty this is what's happening in the
universe in the future at a rate of
doubling of about every 10 billion years
now the idea of inflation is that there
was another thing just like dark energy
it was short-lived
it eventually decayed into matter and
radiation but before that happened it
was also causing the universe to double
in size but not once every 10 billion
years once every 10 to the minus thirty
fifth seconds okay so in just an instant
of time 10 to the minus 30 seconds so
one with you know
I'm sorry a decimal point and you know
yeah they say 30 zeros in a 1 or
something like that and that instant of
time it could have doubled as much as a
hundred thousand times well if you take
something the size of a proton you
double the region the size of a proton
you double it a hundred thousand times
you get to a region which is much
greater than anything we've been able to
see in the universe up to this point we
know why that some you would decide to
do that well with you know we might
suspect to be like opening a soda bottle
it's only the fizzle comes out and it
settles back down again is that the
inflation of the bubbles coming out well
it's not required that so the idea that
there's a beginning doesn't require
inflation doesn't require we have to add
in something just like we have to add in
something to explain dark energy we have
to suppose that in order to explain the
universe we see there had to have been
if it was a beginning right the only way
we can get this smooth universe is to
suppose there was such an element in the
universe that on the one hand causes
inflation and the other hand decayed
away so this is a mathematical theory
it's in serious I thought it's not just
added for cosmology we should we should
say that you know we're not just
inventing things because we that that
particle physics tells us that there
were lots of things called phase
transitions in the early universe the
nature of the universe change the forces
that we now see that look very different
we know that at least two of the forces
that we now see that look very different
the weak and electromagnetic force were
once when the universe was about a
millionth of a second old look very
similar we we think that three of the of
the four forces probably look very
similar at a time around 10 to the minus
35 seconds and when a phase transition
happens just like when ice water turns
ice you could trap energy and and that
trapped energy if it happened in the
early universe could produce inflation
so there are kind of natural mechanism
it's not just something we're okay what
every other hello we should be a little
bit cautious because to get the
inflation we need it can't just be any
old phase transition it turns out has to
be very finely tuned salutely but and
that's a big issue as to why would be so
finely tuned so it's not going to so
there's some of the ingredients you need
naturally but they have to be just so I
understand how you have to be careful
about talking about inflation with the
price of oil and stuff exactly right
there was a
a little bit right the I think the
picture most of us have of the Big Bang
is is absolutely not one of mass being
thrown out from some beginning that's
just that's not it like a much a much
easier way to think about it is well of
course all the math we know today was in
proton you know even protons or quarks
before that but as as you can think of
these galaxies as markers of space it is
the space that the currency of inflation
of all these models is space is space
that's changing its space sets that's
accelerating it's a hard concept is very
hard concept of space and matters at
rest it's a mat matters at the right
that's really weird because in general
relativity you can be arrested moving in
the speed of light at the same time yeah
your arrest locally but some other
regions moving away from you at the
speed of light it's great you know it's
just the way it is just goes yeah okay
question sir
yes I was going to ask a question from
the the visitor from Denmark when you
talk about the I think you called the
entropic principle and it relates to
what the the first gentleman asked the
concept that sort of you know that you
really don't know if there's universe
behind you until you turn around the
wavefunction collapses and you're able
to observe something so can you expand
upon what you were talking about in that
principle and how that interacts with
that concept I don't know how the
entropic principle relates to the
quantum mechanical principles but in a
certain sense the entropic principles
can be said to be merely a principle of
consistency that everything that we
observed and that we know exists they
have to be consistent that with our
being and if that is the case the
entropic principle is not very
interesting it's it's almost a rather
trivial observation and as it was
indicated the the
the standard test whether a statement or
a theory is scientific or not is that it
leads to a certain kinds of predictions
and that these predictions are testable
and I think it's generally agreed that
the entropic principle which has been on
the scene for certainly well 40 years or
something like that has not resulted in
testable predictions and from that point
of view it's really surprising that this
principle is still taken very seriously
I remember when it emerged and became an
issue I saw that it would well that's
the sort of silly ideas which come up
and they would probably evaporate next
year but this did not happen
it's also why let's hope let's hope next
by next year yeah but it's really it's
really dark energy that's so
inexplicable the only act right now
unfortunately the only good explanation
of why it's there at the value it is is
an entropic one now it's it's not very
satisfying but it's it's forced a lot of
physicists to think that maybe that's
the explanation and again I agree that I
hope it I certainly hope it goes away
but if I'm a very brief No so you want
it you'd like to take that you'd like to
find an explanation does away with the
whole anthropic well the dark in the
whole reason for doing science I believe
is that you have to have predictive
power the measure the currency or the
measure the validity or power of the the
value of science is its predictive power
because if it doesn't have that it just
blind faith
that's only doing some other activities
you're doing some other activity right
is not please you have to make a
prediction and you have to test it or
else you just believe it on faith and
right outside neat thing about science
is that most theories are wrong I mean
if they weren't it'd be easy anyone
could do it great I think it's always
important to have alternatives because
they help focus your attention on how to
how to what test to do to McGrane to
gain more confidence about which theory
is right and they also help generate new
ideas new ideas wouldn't webpage so you
that's just not family theories until
you come up with the right one you say
let's try this one let's test it out and
knock it down let's go to the next you
want you want so you want predictive
power yeah that whatever the gorilla in
the room right is this is dark energy
there is no I mean first it was found as
by measurement and there is no theory
that predicts it in any fundamental way
and talking to theorists the problem is
also why is there so little of it right
yeah there should be a lot more of it
first we don't know what it is but there
should be a whole lot more of it yeah
right with that correct there should be
a lot more nothing you should get a lot
more done yeah yeah and it's and you
guys got your hands full I they got and
by the way that's a big question I we
talked about earlier why why is there
anything at all is another you know
interesting our way we want to go into
it now but if that's another fascinating
question we really don't yet have the
answer to do we know why time moves in
this direction and that another
well sometimes moves in that direction
but it's a serious question doesn't time
the arrow doesn't have to go on that
it's a very philosophically fascinating
question a physics question that's still
I mean we have good ideas at some level
about it but it's a time is a really
slippery concept now I would like to
well to protest and at least to your
number here and and to to to argue that
even in cosmology which is an extremely
ambitious science probably the most
ambitious science of all but there are
questions which cannot be answered by
the cosmologists all the physicists
simply questions which are not within
the realm within the power of science to
answer it may be because they are
meaningless or it may be because they
are best answered from other points of
view by philosophers or for that matter
pious theologians and the famous or
infamous question or why is there
anything at all rather than nothing
which is a I mean this is admit a
physical question theologians
have answers to that but it is not a
scientific question although I actually
disagree there I think one of the most
one of the things that got many of us
theorists into cosmology was try and ask
that quit it's amazing that I think that
physics with our understanding of what's
called grand unification suggested you
can understand how a universe which
basically should have ended up with
nothing actually ended up with something
how matter was created of enough yes but
you that's a person you are using the
term nothing right in a shaky and wrong
sense we I mean it's it's very important
to say that that zero energy is totally
different from nothingness nothingness
is a metaphysical concept to which no
physical observable or any measurable
property can be assigned okay it's very
nature and for this reason it cannot be
part of physics yeah is about us sorry
we score a few points on that one like
we're here for one more question whoever
has the mic go ahead guys Dano just
speak up yeah I go oh two question let's
go one at a time okay so long it takes
to answer these questions first can you
tell me the exact name of that Big Bend
project in Switzerland and also is it a
worldwide effort or is how much is NASA
involved in this project
well actually it's not a NASA it's
actually the Department of Energy and
it's called the Large Hadron Collider
the LHC
it's an accelerator and it is a truly
international effort which is really I
think it's a really important to stress
that it's amazing to me it's an effort
each each of the experiments of that
Large Hadron Collider involves thousands
of physicists from hundreds of countries
speaking with dozens of languages
designing machine that that that's
bigger than a Gothic cathedral each of
those detectors has more iron than the
Eiffel Tower that have to fit together
with an accuracy of microns to measure
events that require so much information
that each event which happens a million
times a second
the LHC will generate terabytes of
information and that we are trying to
analyze that it is truly an
international project and it
demonstrates to me one of the greatest
aspects of science that that you know we
can work together and when will the
first experiments happen well the first
its I was just there last week and and
the machine is almost cooled down the
first the the beam is being set up and
in the month of June the beam will begin
to get going and the first collisions
test collisions should begin to be and
what and what do they collide with well
they'll begin to climb by the fall we
won't have day what things will they
collide together protons going around 26
kilometers this direction in 26
kilometers this direction will collide
at four different places producing
little if you wish little mini big bangs
recreating the universe as it was about
a millionth of a millionth of a second
after the Big Bang there was there
wasn't fear that a little black hole
could be created yeah let me tell you
that's not a problem because as as
energetic as those collisions are you
know the universe nature is a lot more
powerful than we are and more energetic
cosmic rays are coming down and striking
the earth every second that are produced
at the LHC and particular the moon so
the fact that the moon has been around
for four and a half billion years with
cosmic rays my barding us makes us
pretty confident that the accelerations
that are happening at the violation I
got time for one more question than we
have - who's got the mic close by raise
your hand okay if the universe is
expanding and the mass is separating
from each other at a mix at a rate of
acceleration that's continuing won't
they reach the speed of light separating
each other and then what will happen in
fact that's one of the things I didn't
get a chance to talk about but in fact
objects in any universe in fact even if
the universe isn't accelerating there
are always regions that are moving away
far faster than the speed of light now
you learn in school that that's not
possible but that's because we lied
really you have to be like a lawyer and
parse a little more carefully objects
can't move through space faster than
speed of light but space can do whatever
the hell it wants and and in fact so in
such a universe and this is really
fascinating in such a universe the
longer we wait the less we will see
because objects that are now moving away
from us less fast than the speed of
light will one day be moving away from
us faster than the speed of light so in
such a universe eventually everything
that isn't bound to us now will
disappear and the universe become cold
and dark and empty Wow
well that's that that's the take-home
message you guys can do whatever the
hell wants to thank you okay Lawrence
Krauss
Paul Stine hotel defrag
you